the big squeeze nate talks about it
every morning and you're driving your
crazy segment you got some more
information on that we sure do so bianca
and heather an inconvenience now
and an even bigger headache yet to come
so in addition to some one lane only
drives on both the north and south on 95
515 during overnight hours the nevada
department of transportation has now
taken a near downtown access ramp
offline for just over a month we're
talking about the casino center 4th
street on-ramp to the north 95. now
endot suggests you stay north on casino
center to bonanza then go west to mlk
that will get you onto the northbound
freeway that's supposed to last until
early november but the bigger more
impactful shutdown this is going to be a
big one eastern is going to be
completely closed under the freeway that
complete closure starts on friday night
going to run until uh just over a week
till october the 10th expect big delays
on these suggested detours and out of
suggesting that you take stuart or
bonanza bonanza up to the north stewart
down to the south or maryland parkway
for north south and they say good luck
to the businesses in the area where ndot
says there will be access you want to
check out the n dot website
i515project.com a lot of detailed
information we've got that link along
with all of our driving and crazy
stories on our website 8newsnow.com
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully and please put
down that phone if there is something
driving you crazy email me traffic
news now 8
com